It's interesting that modern jazz
composers,
some names at a middle that come to
mind,
people like John Coltrane when shorter,
um,
there was always directly,
I'm Sandra,
I'm a n,
a deep appreciation and even a very deep
intuitive understanding of modern
physics.
I'm into their music.
And one of the things I like to do for
fun is actually look for those
connections.
Like literally I talked to music
composers and it's like this hobby of
mine where I will take a culture in song
or the chord changes and try to relate
it to music theory.
I'm at I'm,
and physics.
So one thing I found interesting is the
notion that culture and came up with was
something called,
there was a,
a sort of a musical and a musical
illusion device in saxophone plane.
See a saxophone can play more than one
at a time.
Um,
it's monophonic instruments.
So,
but what culture was able to do was to
come up with illusionary,
reflects on the saxophone record that,
and it was called sheets of sandy color
sheets of sound.
Or another thing that he did was he
figured out ways in which you can go to
higher notes that the sex is naturally
wasn't built to make
and this user's ideas in physics like
nonlinearity for example.
Um,
you know,
that there isn't always a one to one
correspondence between a wave and a
note.
And I mean,
uh,
you know,
um,
one wave,
if I add two waves together,
I get a third wave.
There's not always a one to one
correspondence.
That's the difference between linear and
nonlinear.
And since music is way of cultural,
is able to figure out techniques to do
that,
ways in which,
you know,
you can hear more than one note at a
time.
And how's that relate to physics?
Well,
quantum mechanics is exactly an example
of that,
that a political really can be that if
there is a probability incentive,
a particle being here or here,
then in a sense it's,
you know,
you can think of it as occupying in two
places at the same time until you go and
measure it.
Okay.
And the question is,
well that's hard to get your mind
around,
but in a sense that's what the sheets of
sound Coltrane was doing was like,
because you are playing in many ways,
many different notes on an instrument
that can only play one note at the time,
but there's this overall effect in which
all those notes of coexistence.
So what I'm getting,
what the sheets of sound is going to be
switching between different individual
notes.
So for example,
I'm going to play a d,
I got,
I want my horn,
but
right and I'll play a g,
I'm sorry.
All right.
And that's the.
See if I play them very quickly for
alright.
But if culture and figured out
alternative fingerings,
why plan those notes in a rapid
succession that you get an effect?
Um,
it sounds like.
So that's kind of the example of sheets
of som I'll pissed him off was basically
the sax normally can just go up to 30
this high f sharp.
That's it,
you know,
that's a high f sharp for me.
But then you can go further by using a
nonlinear effect by using your diaphragm
down here,
by forcing the resonance resonance from
down here so I can go up to my highest
sharp.
Hello.
Actually,
I'm working.
Working
on a little album.
Project is almost done and I'm,
the title of the album is call and a lot
of the songs inspired by,
you know,
my love for grid cool ideas in physics
and how it's connected to jazz music in
particular,
but actually it has a lot of it,
it,
it's,
it also explores the idea of diversity
and creativity.
So it uses modern rhythms like a
Brazilian beat versus a regular Tom b
versus a hip hop beat.
So it uses modern rhythms with jazz
improvisations.
Combined it with themes,
let's say I'm and impressions I'm having
to do with cosmology and particle
physics and string theory and the title
of the album will be called mathematics
because when I grew up in the bronx in
the eighties hip hop music,
um,
there was a part of rap music were guys
who battled each other on the streets.
Um,
and you know,
and
sometimes the battle and we'll go into,
you know,
the subject matter would be talking
about science for example,
and they even called it dropping
science.
I'm like Eric,
B and Rakim.
And so I used to take the bus home from
school and these guys would be on the
back of the bus,
you know,
rapping,
battling each other,
drop in science,
so to speak.
And when one day,
you know,
I heard someone say,
yeah man,
I got,
I got enough mathematics.
So it also captures a big part of my,
you know,
what inspired me was that I was already
living in us in sort of a sign that this
rapping and improvisational rapping and
talking about,
you know,
things are voluntary in the universe and
stars exploding that I'm like the star
exploding,
you know,
and you know,
things like this planet rock Afrika
Bambaataa wind the first rap songs out
there.
Um,
so the title of mathematics sort of
brings it all together.